a pesar de la guerra ucrania tiene
previsto cosechar este año 50 millones
de toneladas de cereales sin embargo en
sus siglos todavía están almacenadas las
cosechas del año pasado
solo faltan tres semanas para la nueva
cosecha y algunos de nuestros siglos
siguen totalmente yesos
más o menos siete mil toneladas en este
equivalente a dos trenes cargarlos toma
tiempo
tendremos que encontrar otras soluciones
para el almacenamiento
la red ferroviaria europea no fue
diseñada para sacar del país los
productos agrícolas ucranianos su
capacidad es limitada
víctor discute posibles alternativas con
uno de los administradores
hemos modificado un poco nuestra
estrategia de venta antes buscábamos un
comprador y después nos ocupábamos de la
logística ahora confirmamos primero de
transporte y después buscamos un
comprador pero mire tengo estos
contratos estos son los volúmenes
al día siguiente llegan cinco camiones
cada uno solo podrá transportar 25
toneladas una ínfima parte de la
cantidad almacenada para exportar todos
los cereales que haya almacenados en
ucrania se necesitarían un millón de
estos vehículos
ahora enviamos algunos cargamentos en
camión hasta la frontera terrestre de
ucrania
normalmente en tiempos de paz todo
debería moverse entre él y llegar
directamente a los puertos marítimos
pero los puertos marítimos ucranianos
están ocupados o bloqueados por rusia
decenas de barcos de carga están
inmovilizados desde febrero
en este barco hay 28.000 toneladas de
maíz y hay otras ocho embarcaciones como
están totalmente cargadas bloqueadas en
este puerto el maíz podría poder irse si
permanece aquí
el ejército teme que haya ataques contra
los puertos y nos pide no mostrar ningún
indicio que permita identificarlos hay
poca actividad sólo unos cuantos
camiones llegan a veces para llevarse un
cargamento
oficialmente los puertos no están
cerrados pero no son lugares seguros
desde el comienzo de la invasión diez
barcos han sido atacados incluyendo
embarcaciones con matrícula extranjera
un ciudadano de bangladesh hecho murió
era miembro de la tripulación los
puertos están físicamente bloqueados
como se puede navegar si se corre el
riesgo de ser atacado quien estaría
dispuesto a arriesgarse a sí
a pesar de eso algunos barcos siguen
navegando por las aguas ucranianas a
través del danubio 4 millones de
toneladas de cereales han salido del
país por esta vía por razones de
seguridad está prohibido grabar los
puertos fluviales de ismail y rené ahora
muy activos los barcos llegan desde su
línea en rumanía algunos viajan
directamente hasta los puertos
ucranianos otros recogen los cargamentos
en los puertos rumanos de galati y
braila antes de volver a zarpar el día
de nuestra visita las embarcaciones
ucranianas que se esperaban en braile no
llegaron ideales por un 20
las embarcaciones suelen llegar con
retraso porque se demoran entre 6 y 8
horas en la aduana
para nosotros 8 horas es mucho porque
podríamos cargar 2 o 3 gabarras en ese
lapso
la promesa de la unión europea de
simplificar los trámites todavía no se
ha concretizado
no he visto nada en concreto por
supuesto queremos que todo se haga
correctamente pero habría que acelerar
el procedimiento de otro puntos deben
estar completos la mercancía debe
realizarse pero hay que hacerlo más
rápido el fichero de marfá
la burocracia no es el único problema el
sitio giorgi finalmente atraca en su
línea
tuvimos que esperar 19 días para entrar
al puerto
mañana salvamos hacia ucrania para
cargar los cereales
los retrasos se deben en parte a la
falta de prácticos de puerto
a veces tenemos que regresar a nuestra
casa y dormir cambiarnos de ropa no
podemos trabajar siempre sobre todo por
la noche porque estos barcos son
bastante viejos no están bien equipados
no eres
según él la formación de prácticos
adicionales tomaría seis meses este y
otros dos barcos pasarán la noche aquí
por fin podemos descansar
una vez tuvimos que esperar dos semanas
otra vez una semana y hielo
putin es un cabrón con la capacidad
suficiente en barcos más grandes la
única solución y ponerle fin a esta
guerra vamos a ganar la guerra y todo el
mundo recibirá sus ideales cuando
nuestros puertos estén abiertos todo
saldrá de ahí todo funcionará bien un
gran saludo a macrón de nuestra parte
dígale que nos envíe tanques
entretanto a lo largo de las costas
romanas unos 100 barcos esperan para
poder entrar al danubio